hey everyone it's sarah with register
now sorry and calm and in this video i'm
going to demonstrate for you how to
place electrodes for a five lead to
limit tree monitor now in the hospital a
physician may order a patient to be a
telemetry status where they will wear a
telemetry box during the whole
hospitalization and their heart rate and
rhythm will be monitored by a telemetry
unit the boxes vary in size they can be
relatively big or small depending on the
type of supplies that your hospital
bought and there's five connections that
will go on the chest and they have
different colors and what those colors
really throw people off so here in a
second I'm gonna give you a great way on
how to memorize those colors and I'm
gonna show you exactly where those
little stickers go on the chest now
before you place a monitor on a patient
for a telemetry monitor you'll first
want to prep the skin properly because
if you don't prep the skin properly you
may get a really bad connection
so this is some supplies you will need
in order to prep the chest you will need
some alcohol prep which will just remove
any oils or dirt from the skin you'll
need some exfoliation paper
I call it sand paper it just roughs up
this top layer of the skin so you get a
good connection with your electrode and
then you'll need a packet of electrodes
always make sure your electrodes have
not expired and that the gel which is
behind this little sticky part on the
electrode is nice and moist you don't
want any dry electrodes because if you
do you'll get a lot of artifact and they
won't stick to the skin so let me show
you how to place these electrodes okay
you'll want to expose the chest and
you'll get your to limitary box you'll
put the battery in the box and you'll
get your sites ready to put your little
electrode stickers now on the back of
each electrode there's a little backing
that you'll have to peel off like the
bat and first I like to start over here
on the right side what you had first on
your right side is your right arm lead
and your right lower leg lead and this
will be white and green how I like to
remember that is snow which is why over
grass
so your right arm lead will go in the
second intercostal space at the ribs so
about right in this area and how you
want to prep the skin is you want to
take your alcohol prep and you just want
to clean the skin really good to get
those oils off and then lightly take
your exfoliation paper and just scratch
on the area lightly just to rough it up
and then peel the backing off of your
electrode and place it on the skin and
make sure you put it down really well
and next you'll do your left arm lis and
this is the green like we said and it is
down here right below the lower edge of
the rib cage which is right here on this
mannequin and it's on the non muscular
area so you don't want to put it over
the abdominal muscles so you'll do the
same type of prep you'll clean with
alcohol and you'll lightly scratch and
then you'll put your electrode on so we
have right arm right leg and we have
snow over grass and then let's do our
left arm leads we have left arm and
lower leg so what we'll do is we'll prep
for that and remember watch out for any
pacemakers implanted devices you can
sometimes have sub-q ports or even
pacemakers over here and you never want
to put your electrode over that so
you'll want to go away from that so
you'll clean the skin right here it's a
second intercostal space on the left
side of the body it's literally right
across from your right arm lead and
you'll just take your backing off put it
on second intercostal space and this is
the black lead okay and this is going to
be our left lower leg and this is going
to be the red lead so you have smoke
over fire so clean that area and this is
literally right across from your right
leg lead and it's on the lower part of
where the ribcage is on the non muscular
area and we have one more left and this
will be v1 v1 is the brown lead and
everyone just tries to remember this as
chocolate in the middle so the brown
lead will be at the fourth intercostal
space which will be right in this area
yeah clean your area prep it and then
put your electrode on and you're done
and then you'll connect your wires so
let's go over it again you have snow
over grass smoke over fire and then
chocolate in the middle so you'll
connect your electrodes to this you'll
immediately then call the telemetry unit
for your Hospital make sure they are
picking up the patient that they're
getting a nice clear EKG the batteries
are working that you put in and that
they have the right patient information
because you never want because if you
had a patient in that room and you
didn't clear out that information they
might have another patient in there so
always make sure that and that is how
you set up for a five lead telemetry
monitor thank you so much for watching
and be sure to check out my other videos
on how to place electrodes for a 12-lead
EKG and their placements and be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
thank you so much